all right so off the top here when you
think black owned business
what comes to mind for me what comes to
mind when i think of black owned
businesses
is the struggle and hard work and what
it took to get here
i don't think people understand how hard
it is to be an entrepreneur in general
but then to be a black entrepreneur
is even harder because there's a lot
more obstacles
and stereotypes and things that come
with
just being a minority in business in
general that you have to overcome to get
an even
level playing field at times so that's
what i think of hard work dedication
motivation
drive and those type of things perfect
we'll get to the
explanation of those things in a minute
but first i want to ask um
what do you think other races and
cultures
what do you think their perceptions are
of black owned businesses maybe the
common misconceptions
i think the common misconceptions that
people have of black owned businesses is
that we're
unorganized we're cheap we're
for lack of a better word ghetto
and that we are not professional
and it's really far from the truth in
order to get open
a lot of times you have to be even more
on top of things
than anybody else and i always hear
i've even heard in my my own career you
know you've got to be twice as good
yes when you're black what does that
mean to you and how do you
combat that i totally agree with the
fact that you have to be twice as good
and you have to be twice as
knowledgeable you have to be
more prepared it definitely
is as a woman in general in a
world of executives that are men
you already have to do that but as a
minority
it takes it even up a notch and it's
definitely
a real statement you have to be twice as
organized have to be
twice as professional twice as
knowledgeable
and you shouldn't have to be right but
it's just the reality
um what do you what do you think
blackboard businesses do for our
black community and minority owned
businesses do for the general
i think it helps our whole community as
a whole as far as
helping generational wealth and in your
in your family and
and that we can it's something we can
pass along
knowledge is something we can pass along
community support
it's huge for the community and i think
it's huge for
all communities and in order to also
separate the economic gaps in the in
your states and in your community as a
whole
it just really bridges the gaps and i
want to know maybe some numbers if you
have them just throw them out at me
um how many black owned dispensaries are
in las vegas and
in comparison to your counterparts i'm
one of the only black
women owners in the cannabis industry um
i'm the only one in nevada that has any
equity in it
and and as an operator as well with my
partners
so in this industry as in general it's
extremely hard to get in
in general as a whole even in executive
positions management positions and the
whole nine
so it's very difficult um for me to be
here
in general i'm not supposed to be here
and
um there's only i'm the only one and how
does it make you feel that you're the
only one
how do we how do we change that it's
it's
it's very disheartening um i do a lot of
advocacy work for this
reason because it's only right as we
talked about what
black business ownership means to the
community this is what it means it means
bringing other people up with you
sharing the knowledge trying to help the
community as a whole
and not just yourself and so it is
it's a very sad situation a lot of
regulations and laws need to be
put in place to support black ownership
and black entrepreneurship
and this is this industry and other
industries i'm involved in as well
same thing it's just you know it's it's
very disheartening but it's a fight it's
a struggle and
we got to fight through it and let's
talk about now those disparities you
mentioned earlier
and the obstacles and struggles that are
different from your counterparts
let's talk about the ones you've noticed
and the ones that you've actually faced
as a business owner
when i go into meetings and things like
that i'm the only one
that looks like me usually
i look at a place i get treated out of
place like i'm not supposed to be there
or i'm supposed to be serving the drinks
or something different that i'm not
in the capacity that i'm meant to be
there for
um so there's disparities in general um
when it comes to the perception of you
even being the owner when they step into
a building
they don't they're not the first person
they think of
when they think black ownership our
ownership in general
you know they just don't think it um
but i i noticed those despair these and
this industry but as well as other
business industries
as a whole so and um
what about entrepreneurship in las vegas
let's kind of give us
a synopsis of what you think of the
entrepreneurship here
and why it's booming i grew up in las
vegas
i've been here pretty much my whole life
i knew early early on that this was the
place i wanted to be
after college for business it's a fast
growing city
there's a lot of opportunity here it is
tough it's very
hard to get into a lot of industries
sometimes you have that good old boy
system
and there's a lot of playing politics
and
different industries but as a whole
there's a lot of opportunity here you
really have to hit the ground floor
though
with change in the industry you want to
be involved in or get
really involved in legislation to make
sure you get a fair shake
when it comes to entrepreneurship but i
think nevada could do a better job at
supporting but i do think we have people
in office that are worried about it and
are really trying to make
make change and you mentioned
you mentioned you need to build a team
so talk about networking
as a black business owner and how you
you know do that here
so in a lot of different industries
especially
this industry here it's it's definitely
not something that usually is one person
that can do it by themselves it's a very
very complex
business so you do need a team of people
good team
around you to support you you need a
good community base
to come support you we we are very
fortunate because
the community we do a lot of community
advocacy work we do a lot of community
give back
i've done that prior to this business
i've always been involved in that
and i think that's why the community as
a whole gives back as well to us
they support us we support them and i
think that's what most businesses
really need to embrace is that it's not
one-sided
it's not how can you make me money how
can i get more customers is how can we
help each other how can we help the
community how can you help me as a
business owner
and i think if you really embrace that
philosophy
it'll come you know the business will
come because people know your intentions
and so that's the support that we get
here we're very fortunate that way
the community is very supportive they
know how well and how much we work into
the community as well
so i think it's very important and
is las vegas a new example of the black
wall street
i don't necessarily i don't think that
las vegas is the example of black's wall
street right now
i definitely think that we are we got a
lot of people working hard
to get a fair shake in a lot of
different industries and get
support by our state legislators
and i think that we're on the path
to actually have that and build that
type of community
and let's talk about another process and
experiencing opening up top notch here
top notch was uh has been you know
we were pioneers here you know we it was
a historical situation for us to be
involved in
um so i'm very proud of that but it
definitely
has been harder than any business i've
been involved in
um you know compliance measures
all the different things you have to do
to get into it and as much money as it
takes to be involved
and what people don't fail to realize is
that being that it's not federally legal
it's also very expensive to operate
not just to run
dave day but even taxes and other things
on the back end of the business
it's very very expensive so
you know the experience of doing it has
been um very
challenging at times but it's definitely
worthwhile
because we see what this does to help
people
we know that we're innovative and we're
the pioneers and we're leading the way
for others and that's why we go back and
do the advocacy work
and speak against um you know social
injustice issues that
this industry was built around so it's
just
you know it's definitely a challenge it
has been extremely difficult but
it's definitely one that i would fight
any day to have
can you expand a little bit on the
social injustices within this industry
that you mentioned you have to
tell the whole story but just a little
bit yeah this industry was built
on the on the backs of minorities you
know it was
something that we've been doing since
the beginning of time
even back into slavery times when we
were working the land
you know we've always been involved in
and um different areas of different
industries and we really don't get
this the justice when it comes to being
able to be involved in the industry
when it finally materializes and
monetizes for people to
to to be a part of um
the war on drugs incarcerates you know
minority people four to ten times more
than
their counterparts and that's how
this industry um basically
built the back uh built on the backs of
those type of people they're out there
trying to make a living or being
involved and trying to be
um involved in this type of industry
and unfortunately you know having any
type of cannabis
you know they might go to jail or
whatever the case may be so
there's a lot of social injustice there
um the war on drugs did
a lot of damage to the black and brown
communities and
now it's legal in in states
you know in different states so it's you
know something we need to fix
and let's talk about top notch now in
particular what sets you guys apart from
you know the other dispensaries or other
health centers in town i think
what sets us apart is some of the things
i mentioned as far as give back
to the community how important the
community is to us and that's our
ground uh grassroots you know that's
where we really came from
is just working with the people and
knowing what they want and
and really being hands-on with the
community
and so i think that sets us apart we we
kind of consider ourselves
um the cheers of the industry if you
remember that old show you might be too
young for that but
um you know we know every we know our
customers names we know what they like
you know we're very personable
um people come from all over to see us
um
and uh we're like a big family here but
yet we
compete with some of the big giants in
town and we're able to do that
because i feel like we're so connected
to
our base and did the pandemic
hit you guys at all or how did that
affect you the pandemic definitely
affected us we we lost personnel we had
to cut back
just like any other industry the only
difference is this was an essential
business so it was very hard for people
to get their medication and things that
help them
with different physical elements or
medical elements that they may be
suffering so
it was very tough um for us and for our
customers as well
but things you know since we were able
to open um
full fully open um
we still have a lot of restrictions and
things because of coven and the pandemic
and things that are going on but
but we're definitely ramming back up and
and looking good it's it's definitely
affected us though
during that time and i just want to go
back to you mention that top-notch
there's a historical you know pioneering
aspect to it
can you expand on that a little bit just
so i have the knowledge
yeah i mean it was you know we're the
first ones it was like prohibition
just the same thing is when they
legalized you know alcohol
and suddenly you're the first person
that can sell it
legally in the state and so we were the
first ones
licensed along with a lot of the firsts
we were one of the first ones open
and you know that's that's history
and being the only minority
african-american woman
in the industry here in nevada i was
able to be a part of that history
all right and how should people treat
and support black-owned businesses
minority-owned businesses
i don't think people should look at
black owned businesses
like they look at all businesses you
know i don't think that people should
get a leg up just because they're a
minority owner
in a sense you'd still have to have
quality products you have to have good
customer service a lot of things you
should
have in place as a business owner in
general so i feel like people get
this a misunderstanding when we say
support it's not support no matter what
it's just support like you would support
anybody else
and i feel like a lot of times
people think well you know i gotta i
gotta
support a black business because just
because you're black and
i'm saying support me because i'm just
as good or better
than anybody else and don't use
stereotypes when you're thinking about
the type of business that i may run
all right do you have any encouraging
words or words of wisdom for people out
there
who you know might want to start a
business and feel discouraged
you know right now at this time i think
it's still important
to learn as much as you can about the
business you want to get involved in
you have to educate yourself more than
your competitors
um you have to be more twice as
motivated like we said so
earlier you have to put in the work um
you can't want to be a business owner
just because you're good at something
you really have to do the research do
the work
put in long long hours
and know that it's not going to end
anytime soon but
in the long run it's well worth it and
it's something you can pass down to your
family
and it helps you grow as a person and um
and and and better your situation
as a whole beautiful and lastly um
sean lashon can you just just briefly
say you know what she does and that it's
pretty special to have a black
female manager as well in this industry
yes so we also have a
black female manager of the dispensary
and
and once again in this industry there's
a very small percentage of
women executives and or management and
on top of that women minority man in in
management and she's one
of very few in nevada as well
she's been here since day one
with us working with us and growing the
company and she's moved up
all and worked her way through and
that's what should happen if you work
hard
and you um really put your best foot
forward
and you are talented you should have the
opportunity just like anybody else
you should be treated equally and make
just as much money as any man out there
and she does it and we recognize it and
that's what you need to do we're very
diverse
in our staffing we have everything you
can think of and
every culture um you can think of so
we're very very much into diversity and
not just
minorities you know we want you know
every race
in here we want this dispensary to
represent
people who actually purchase the product
and it's everybody okay it's not one
type of person
it's every type of person and that's
what our staff represents